was that exciting to watch hey guys
grace here and it's a late night
Saturday session for you and I so my
friend internet friend Jim Windsor sent
me this microphone it's a wireless
microphone that I am not using right now
because I just filmed this video a
couple minutes ago and I started editing
it and then I realized that and I filmed
it using this microphone and I realized
that the audio I think I [ __ ] it up
because it started like this oh my god
hello totally normal right and then it
ended like this so somewhere somehow I
[ __ ] up using this thing so I am rear
according it now but thank you Jim so so
much for sending that to me I got it
today and I was so excited to use it
just me to figure it out so in the video
that I just shot and I don't even know
why I'm reshooting this I guess I feel
like I owe you guys a video I don't owe
you I want to make a video but I didn't
even have a point in the first thing you
know some of the second one is not
obviously there's no pencil sharpening
and it's not gonna make point I'm where
your hood tonight let's go walk it over
that together
so these Saturday sessions are just me
quacking to you and telling you more
personal stories of things that happen
to me in my everyday life I thought all
day today about something that was
interesting to talk about I couldn't
think of anything and this is the
closest that I have to it so last night
I was leaving an improv show it's just
an awesome and fun improv show and I was
on the subway at like 11 o'clock at
night and somebody's late at night are
usually more inebriated than subways
during the day um but that really has no
wait for this story that where my
thoughts are not clear in this vlog I
will let you know that now I'll be clear
about that so I'm on the subway last
night and I look around and it's pretty
crowded subway I'm standing but I
usually stand on the subway
which is another thing that for another
video later on I feel like I'm the weird
one because I like standing on the
subway anyway so I'm on the so when I'm
standing and there's a plenty of other
people standing it's pretty crowded and
I noticed that three couples in the
subway car that I'm in three of the
couples are the ratio of cute asian girl
and tall nerdy white guy and that was so
fascinating to me maybe curious that
there were these three couples in a car
that maybe had only five couples total
four maybe and three of them were tiny
fashionable Asian girl and nerdy hipster
tall lanky white dude it was so
interesting and I must have creep them
out because I was looking at the whole
time and I don't know why I'm telling
you this story but it was so fascinating
to me and is this like a new cultural
phenomena I I don't know I've seen my
thoughts are not clearly formed enough
about this to talk about it with a point
or a purpose other than it made me so
curious is this something that's
happening I mean I know I'm John Lennon
probably started the trend I don't know
what I want to say about it
nothing bad of course but it just was so
curious curious to me what am i talk I
don't even know what I don't have a
point to this but it was just something
that was curious to me and this YouTube
channel is me talking about things that
are curious hmm I guess sure please
don't take offense to this I'm most
worried about offending people too
that's something I think it's more in me
than it is in society but I'm always
worried about offending someone cuz I
don't want it be dumb and like misspeak
and say something dumb you know when
people are dumb and they miss me
say something dumb I don't want to be
one of those dumps and I've talked too
much right now and you're probably like
why am I still watching this there has
been no point made
there's been no peak of interest at any
point I ha I don't know I'm sorry guys I
just wanted to talk and my apartment
it's empty right now and so I'm talking
to you
that sad sounding I'm gonna go drink the
rest of my margarita
bye nice huh